earlier today
sue gray published her final report
which i commissioned to get to the
bottom of things and to set the record
straight and i'm grateful to her for her
work
she's identified a number of failings
some official some political and some
that i accept are entirely my own for
which i take full responsibility
i want to start by saying that i'm
humbled by what has happened and i renew
my wholehearted apology
for the gathering in the cabinet room
on the 19th of june
2020 my birthday for which i received a
fixed penalty notice
now that sue gray has completed her
inquiry and everyone can read her report
i want in all humility and without
mitigating what has happened to offer a
few points of context
10 downing street is not just my
official residence but the headquarters
of the government where hundreds of
people work and because they directly
support the prime minister the
regulations allowed them to continue
attending their offices for work
purposes throughout the lockdowns
sue gray describes them as tight-knit
groups of officials and advisors who
worked long hours under difficult
conditions
these were the public servants who
secured the ppe that saved many lives
established the biggest testing program
in europe and enabled the development
and distribution of the vaccines that
succeeded in protecting so many people
when some of these officials and
advisors were leaving their jobs i
briefly attended gatherings to thank
them for everything they had done
because i believe that recognizing
achievement and
preserving morale are essential duties
of leadership
the police did not find my attendance at
these occasions to be a breach of the
rules
but they found otherwise in respect of
some of those gatherings after i had
left or when i was not in the building
dining street and the cabinet office
together have hundreds of rooms and
again i say there's not in any way to
extenuate my personal responsibility but
to give context to these events
and i i was in particular appalled
to learn that there have been multiple
examples
in sue gray's phrase of disrespectful
and poor treatment
of cleaning and security personnel
and this afternoon i personally
apologized to those dedicated members of
staff
for what happened and i expect
anyone who behaved in that way to do the
same
as sue gray acknowledges i have acted on
her recommendations to make a series of
changes
10 downing street now has its own
permanent secretary charged with
upholding the highest standards i've
appointed a new leadership team
including a new chief of staff and a new
principal private secretary
and i've made it easier for any member
of staff to voice any worries they may
have
and sue gray says that she is reassured
by this reform
and it is precisely because
i have learned this lesson that i feel
an even greater weight
of responsibility
to deliver on the priorities of the
british people and lead our country
through some of the most challenging
times in recent history i will work
every hour to ease the hardship caused
by the rising cost of living to protect
our nation from the aftershocks of
kovid to stand firm against putin's
aggression and unite and level up across
our united kingdom that is the mission
that drives this government and that is
the mission i will continue to pursue